事實上40歲開始投資並不晚。
我認識很多同事,
他們其實真正開始投資都是40歲。
為什麼?因為他可能35歲才回來開始當教授。
所以可能前面幾年都還沒有辦法投資。
所以40歲開始投資的人很多。
所以不用太焦慮。
火速開戶做任務囉
36到50歲是多數人質疑成長最快的階段
但同時也是支出與責任暴增的時期
在這樣的衝刺期
該如何看待資產配置還有人生規劃
在節目開始之前
也不要忘記訂閱按贊開啟小鈴鐺
以免錯過最新的資訊喔
那我們歡迎今天的來賓陳彥吳教授
教授您好
你好
很高興又再次來到這邊跟大家分享
老師您曾經提到說
36到50歲是人生衝刺速度最高的階段
那很多人在這段時間會覺得賺錢變快了
但同時呢支出也是變得非常驚人
那反而會比較容易鬆懈
你認為這段時間最需要警惕的財務風險是什麼呢
我覺得這是一個蠻重要的問題
因為我們說大概這個算是Golden Age的時候
因為這段時間你在人生的方向的拿捏
或者是你的這個財富的累積
都是一個比較重要的一個階段
那在這個時候呢
因為你賺
就是說財富累積的快的時候
有些時候難免也會有比較多需要花錢的時候
那花錢花的多的時候
有時候你會忽略掉說
我這樣的消費模式是不是合理的
因為大家可能會很自然會覺得說
這麼辛苦的工作應該可以花一點
這些錢應該是可以做得到
但是有點忘了一件事
就是財富的累積
它是有階段性的
那在這個階段裡面
你本來就是屬於
責任開始上升的時候
那有比較多的支出
雖然是正常
但是事實上
它也更需要來回頭思考一下
這些財富累積的高峰期
是不是應該要有
用來做更多
能夠產生未來價值的
這個資產配置
在同時面對房貸育兒
甚至是父母照顧的多重壓力下
您會怎麼建議這個階段觀眾
去思考資產配置該如何做彈性的調整
在這個階段啊
的確我們有好多事要做
那如果一般來說有想要結婚的朋友
他應該是在差不多35歲以前會結婚
那當然有部分的人是35到40歲中間結婚
所以如果你想結婚
十之八九年大家都會想買房子
那大概可能就是大家的期望
那買房子這件事情事實上它是人生最重要的一個財務的選擇跟資產配置
那我們剛剛有講就是說
你30在這個35歲以前
應該有一些工作經驗累積了一小部分的這個資產
可能不多
但是你的第一桶金300萬500萬
可以讓你去做投機款的部分
那當然多多少少我們的父母親也會做一點幫忙
所以呢投期款你只要準備到
其實我是蠻鼓勵大家
儘量可以的話
可以先做第一次房子的自產
因為自產有一個好處是
它某種程度可以抑制你的消費的衝動
因為房貸這件事情
基本上就是一個承諾支付
你承諾每一年
可能前兩年是先還利息
可是慢慢的本金開始還的時候
這壓力是會變得比較多的
所以呢剛剛我們前面有講到說
說不小心會花錢花太多這件事情
某種程度繳房貸是可以抑制的
那育兒的部分
我想小孩大概都是我們生命的延伸
所以很多新生兒的父母
小孩子一出來都會想說
我一定要給他最好的教育
那我想給小孩最好的教育是
要能夠協助小孩找到合適的未來的方向
當然要給他有一個相對具有競爭力的教育模式
那如果要這樣的話
你就要也要同步的思考
要給小孩子準備所謂的教育基金這件事
所以我們非常鼓勵有生小孩的爸媽
在小孩子出生的時候就要開始做這個投資的部分
在原來我們講年輕的時候
你為你自己的第一桶金去累積這個財富
每個月不用很多幾千塊
那慢慢當你收入上升
你可以變成一萬塊兩萬塊
那這個一萬塊兩萬塊上升到這個時候
我們可能繳房貸一個月五萬塊的房貸
然後小孩的基金
因為你小孩剛出生
所以一開始也不用很多
可能是也是可以從五千塊
甚至三千塊都有可能
因為小孩還有很長
十年到十二年的時間才會念國高中
所以事實上越早時間準備是越好的
那父母在這段時間
其實最重要的是讓父母身體健康這件事
因為身為36歲到50歲之間
有一些父母都還沒有退休
那有一些父母慢慢的退休了之後
其實最重要的是身體健康
所以換個角度來說
36到50歲之間
我們的爸媽都還算是能夠照顧自己
所以這一段時間的壓力很多時候是在於
我們自己年輕人怎麼去建構自己的家庭
所以這個時候呢
要切記一件事
就是在你賺了很多的錢底之下
在房貸的投資上面
小孩子的教育基金上面
然後更多的話
也許是下一個階段去做資產配置
所以我還是要回到原來剛剛前面談的
就是這個時候的收入很高
然後花費很高
但是要切記這裡的花費的需要性
除了我們平時的需要之外
然後還有建立社會資產
就是社會資本之外
那是不是應該要有更多的比例
是應該要拿來做投資
那我想這段時間
最大的投資需求應該是房貸了
如果你買一個2000萬的房子
那你一開始可能有300到500萬的自備款
然後你貸個1500萬左右
30年期每個月大概繳五萬五六萬之間的這個房貸
那事實上對於一個雙薪家庭來說
家庭的月收有12萬塊的話
那我想這個6萬塊以內是可以接受的
那當然剩餘的6萬塊生活上就當然是比較拮据一點
或者是比較緊繃一點
但是如果你有在更多的話
就是你的收入有更多的話
那你就會有更相對的能力
再去做其他的投資的配置
那我們再來請問教授
36到50歲這個階段在投資策略上
應該是以追求資產成長為主
還是該逐步轉向更穩定
風險配置更低的配置呢
36歲到50歲
事實上離退休還有蠻長一段時間
你也是人生事業發展最高峰的時候
所以事實上
在很多時候很多人會說
我是不是應該要小心一點
因為我的工作上已經是一個蠻充實的階段
但是在這個地方有一個重點
就是在於你的資產配置的模式
譬如說我們剛剛提到
如果你有買房子
每個月要繳五六萬
甚至更高的房貸的時候
那這個部分的房貸的需要
一定是來自於你的本業
你的薪水的收入
本業有的而不是來自投資報酬的部分
所以那另外呢
如果是我們要投資未來
譬如說我如果是以投資我小孩子的
這個教育基金
那小孩剛出生的話
你有10年到15年的時間
投資小孩教育基金
這個時間事實上是很長的
那更不要講
如果你是在準備你個人更長遠的
下一個階段的財務目標
時間這麼長的前提之下
事實上風險的承擔是還是可以的
那只是說你要去思考
因為這一段區間你的財務目標很多
那當你財務目標很多的前提之下
你要看哪些是短期的
哪些是中期的
哪些是長期的
短期的需要比較多的話
那你可能就要有增加一定比例的
這個低風險的這個配置
那如果大部分都是長期的
那你就可以還是保留比較大部位的投資
是在長期風險高的這個部位上面
那最後想請教教授
有不少觀眾是在40歲之後才開始認真投資
他們會擔心起步太晚而感到焦慮
老師有什麼建議呢
事實上40歲開始投資並不晚
我認識很多同事
他們其實真正開始投資都是40歲
為什麼因為他可能35歲才回來開始當教授
所以可能前面幾年都還沒有辦法投資
所以40歲開始投資的人很多
所以不用太焦慮
那為什麼我說不用焦慮
因為事實上40歲也還算年輕
因為現在大家都是
退休年紀都稍微晚了嘛
都是60 65以後
那事實上你投資的時間
走還蠻長的
所以事實上不用焦慮
那如果你不知道要投資什麼
我覺得還是一樣
就是被動式的投資最安全
有些人會想要說
說我已經這麼老了
可不可以在短一點的時間
賺更多的錢
那我只能跟你說
在事實的真相
就是所有想要短期獲利的人
事實上大部分都是沒有得到
他們想要的成果
所以還是回到原始點
就是財務規劃跟投資的標的
都應該要有個明確
未來的財務需求
所以應該要先想清楚
你的財務需求在哪裡
如果有清楚的財務需求
事實上什麼時候來投資都是很可以的
謝謝陳彥如教授今天和我們分享
中年衝刺期如何在高收入高支出的壓力下
重新看待資產配置還有人生的節奏
下一集我們要把時間再更往前推
當人生走到50歲之後
很多事情開始出現變化
工作的角色不同
花錢方式也不同
記錄必須提前準備退休規劃的關鍵階段
那最後喜歡我們的影片也不要忘記
訂閱按贊開啟小鈴鐺哦
那我們下集再見
拜拜
掰掰